you
first of all I don't I don't really
believe in the word sustainable because
I don't want to sustain what we have
right now I'm really not interested in
that at all and I and I don't I don't
like the use of that word and I think I
don't think we have a proper word right
now for the kind of movement or the
recalibration of our thinking that's
required i don't i don't think we have
the proper vocabulary for it yet but
because because i think sustainable
connotes this idea that we want to
continue down the way the path that
we're going which i don't think is
tenable or interesting and all
sustainable isn't very sexier or like
exciting either like i don't want to
sustain you know i want to thrive or
something like that I think sustaining
is just sounds really meager and
impoverished and kind of pathetic and
sad really and and I don't think the
word green really does it either though
it's really easy catchphrase I suppose
or catch word I don't know it's hard to
be optimistic honestly I don't know i
think it's an architect or designer you
have to be in some way because you
believe in the future i think in general
you'll see artists tend to be more
pessimistic and artists and designers
and architects tend to be more
optimistic right that's what you're paid
to do is as an architect is believed in
the future and build for it and create
the future where's artists tend to be
more critical and point out the problems
and more pessimistic in general so if
you're at all optimistic or create
something for the future as an artist
you're called utopian and suddenly
you're bunched in a pack of other of
other people who who've made work like
that so there's interesting distinctions
that happen between the two disciplines
I think I don't know where we're headed
I think in terms of environmental
movement I think we're I think we're
going to be meeting a sequential series
of crises that we're going to have to
deal with and those crises are going to
have to force us to live in radically
different ways and we won't know how
we're going to deal with it until we
come to it but if you look at the past
how we've dealt with it we're we're able
as a species of humans to have to turn
in a dime pretty quickly when we have to
or if
faced with a crisis and that's what's
going to happen basically there's going
to there's going to be a moment where
food is a crisis and we're going to have
to change radically and we'll deal with
it as we have to or or energy or any one
of them but I mean unfortunately it
seems like we're not really able to
mobilize quickly until we're not eating
or we can't breathe or you know you know
already we have a certain number of days
every year in Los Angeles where children
can't play outside because of the air
quality so if even that can't can't
force people to think differently about
how they're living I don't I don't know
what what the threshold is but you know
there is a threshold and then there's a
radical change because even in the
evolution of different species you can
see a species kind of evolving over a
straight line and then all of a sudden a
sudden shift happens so things don't
happen always at a gradual continuous
arc but there's their sudden jolts and
you know i think i think you know we've
seen that the beginning of that